les chéris vous avez vu michel cymes
alors rien à france 2 il est fainéant il
est vener alors le docteur très
médiatique qui a régulièrement pris la
parole voilà depuis sa côte de
popularité
là on a pris un wilko 12h09 et michel
cymès a été souvent cible d'attaqués
pour les boulettes qu'il a pu dire
hier il a fait une annonce sur europe 1
voilà sur toutes les critiques qu'il a
reçus il se prépare à contre-attaquer
tous ses détracteurs regarder il a dit
je vais attaquer ou contre-attaqué
apparemment michel cymes il a un
thermomètre mais durant la crise du coc
vite 19 les médecins sont devenus les
nouveaux animateurs télé parmi eux
michel cymes mais comme beaucoup le
célèbre docteur a eu du mal à fournir
des informations exactes durant la crise
relayant parfois des informations
incomplètes ou erronées il s'est
retrouvé au coeur de plusieurs
polémiques
aujourd'hui michel cymes est de retour
et il compte bien faire payer tous ceux
qui l'ont critiqué sur europe 1 il s'en
est pris directement aux journalistes
j'ai appris qu'on pouvait me faire dire
des choses que je n'ai jamais dit et qu'
il n'y a pas que des professionnels
compétents dans le métier de journalisme
avant de poursuivre en précisant sa
pensée la fameuse grippe est je n'ai
jamais prononcé ce mot quelqu'un l'a dit
un jour et ça a été repris par tous
ensuite comme il ya quelques
journalistes qui font que du copier
coller que de la vraie recherche et
d'investigation et si la crise du
coronavirus commence petit à petit à se
faire oublier il compte bien en faire de
même pour son bad buzz j'ai fait le dos
rond là pendant quelques semaines mais
voilà je vais commencer
à expliquer ma vérité alors michel cymes
veut se venger de ses détracteurs j'aime
ou j'aime pas voilà michel cymes qui est
en ce qu'on appelle dans une extrême
race rare ces derniers temps donc il
s'est pas mal fait critiquer et souvenez
vous le 10 mars sur europe 1 c'est ça
qui lui est critique et il vient de dire
qu'il a dit le contraire regardez il
avait relativisé le virus avec le 10
mars
et ça bien entendu on a retrouvé les
images et alors et vous êtes inquiet
vous personnellement dans non je mange
un enjeu absolument pas inquiet bon
c'est un virus de plus c'est que l'on
dit souvent c'est une forme de grippe
vous avez en ans parfois dans certaines
années on a entre 8000 et 10000 morts
par an de grippe est ce que vous pensez
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un est
contaminée aux moeurs de la grippe on
fait une dépêche afp imaginez un peu le
nombre de dépêches qu'on aurait voilà
alors donc pour les images sont là
répète il ya plein de médecins on a vu
plein de médecins non nous petit public
et le professeur a aussi au départ il
est grand mais eddy khaldi nom pouvait
pas défendre l'indéfendable
mais michel cymes chez le médecin le
plus connu de france grâce à pascal fan
de lui non plus que je trouve pas
logique c'est que lui il se retire des
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il dit ça c'est
pas pour moi je veux pas aller et heures
ça m'intéresse pas et là il revient il
veut se venger et donc c'est un peu
pathétique en fait je pense à peu près
au moment où on s'écarte il faut il faut
continuer sa route après giraldi
d'avouer qu'il en a pris plein la gueule
pour enfin vrai que le voilà après mais
moi je suis pas fan et je dis là je le
défends parce que moi j'aime pas quand
les mecs qui s'en prennent plein la
gueule là en ce moment c'est devenu la
nouvelle victime michel cymes moi qui
adore ça vous dérange ou pas ben moi je
trouve que c'est un peu ridicule parce
que j'ai trouvé que tous les médecins
globalement avez dit tout et n'importe
quoi pendant ces cris non mais c'est lui
qui a pris part à la gueule michel alors
vous le savez dans ce soir chez ba ba il
y avait même jean pierre foucault qui
avait mis un petit tacle à michel cymes
voilà jean pierre et jean pierre
vraiment lui alors je vous dis il a
aucune inimitié personne jean-pierre
ellien ans matelot rien à prouver et
c'est vrai que voilà c'était maintenant
émotions ils avaient dit qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de gens qui avaient dit que
c'était une grippe qui n'avait pas été
non plus très méchant avec michel parce
que jean-pierre il n'est jamais méchant
et c'est vrai que voilà il ya une
archive d'une interview qui le met dans
l'embarras
regardez je vous montrais après vous
allez nous dire c
celle archives d'une interview de
combinés qui la donnent à combiner
l'excellent site combiné en 2018 dans
celle ci il expliqué qu'il se verrait
bien confié une mission au gouvernement
ça avait l'air tout le monde regarde et
surtout avec agnès buzyn que j'admire
beaucoup si on me confie une mission qui
va avec mes convictions à part si un
jour c'était un gouvernement d'extrême
droite ou d'extrême gauche je refuserais
mais aujourd'hui sur blement des jeux
fra voilà comme unique j'adore et que
j'embrasse d'asie des leurs voilà le
patron de combinés et voilà il est des
patrons de combiné super c'est super ce
qu'ils font et ils sont excellents oui
oui on lui est tombé dessus par dont
cyril retomber dessus parce que dès
qu'il ya un micro il est là toi t'as
shehata marché y aura micro les rivales
[Rires]
des kia micro il parle c'est tellement
beau c'est tellement c'est tellement
beau quelqu'un qui s'excuse quelqu'un
qui dit c'est vrai je suis d'accord j'ai
dit des bêtises je regrette j'ai parlé
un petit peu rapidement mais voilà pour
autant rien de grave je serai plus
attention la prochaine fois il serait il
aurait été sympathique soir est un héros
non il dit des conneries et l'image de
commencer à dire mais vérité mais qui
les disent déjà tout ce qu'on était
malade elle ment discipline voilà et
revient en plus en force
il a fait une bêtise et repeindre
l'agressivité c'est quand même si c'est
tout ce qu'on déteste ce monsieur n'est
plus vraiment qu un ego sur deux jambes
et véritablement y mettait détestable il
en train de devenir auprès de beaucoup
de gens parce qu'effectivement voilà on
voit c'est dingue parce que des titres
préférés des voix et là c'est une
dégringolade de cette crise du
coronavirus mdc la cat et parce qu'il a
pris tous les symptômes de l'animateur
et du mauvais animateur c'est que
maintenant effectivement il a un ego
comme ça il ne parle que de lui veut son
show gecimed chez machin et du coup il
ouvre sa gueule en permanence et quand
on loue votre ont fini par dire des
bêtises mais il y aurait elle est ce que
alors je mange ardent une question après
je me fais l'avocat du diable et vous le
savez voilà et je le dis je sais pas
c'est pas un ami michel cymes mais bon
mine de rien est ce qu'on peut lui lui
quand même lui
voilà essayé d'être un petit peu
indulgent avec lui parce que michel
cymes et le un tel succès quand c'était
celle a été l'animateur préféré des
français franchit le dise ces règles
c'est quoi ils époque j'ai eu la grosse
tête on peut donc saluer tourner la tête
aussi
comme le disent plutôt que d'insulter
rim est pourtant vrai ça va tomber et
menacent ils menacent ceux qui ont eu le
doigt sur ces conneries c'est bien non
et là on puisse il dit j'aurais accepté
un poste au ministère la santé sont
allés creuser un vieux pénis qui veut
qu'on lui ait pas proposé qui décès sur
le sol assure le bureau qu'un masque
aucun vaccin ni rien du tout et puis
franchement chaud chaud ça incroyable
qui sont à l'aise révélé moi moi la
seule chose que je vous demande c est ce
qu on peut pas faire des erreurs on en a
tous fait nous dominons n'est pas là
mais là je parle pas du métissage pas de
l'animateur non non non non mais moi je
parle de ça ils les médecins sur 10 ans
il est médecin de formation d'animatrice
ils sont tous contents que si samedi
mathieu il a eu beaucoup ont fait des
erreurs les médecins qui étaient sur les
plateaux est ce qu ont avancé un peu à
vue mais tous disaient qu'il fallait
faire très attention tous dit qu'elle
est respectée les chiba rien n'y a pas
tellement connu comme médecin qui a dit
ça ce n'est qu'au bout qu il ya légiste
bariani comme boucle la griffe c'est une
grippe comme une autre il ça risque rien
allez on va clôturer la mission pouvoirs
ça vraiment au cru auraient pu moi je
pense j'aime pas dans ce que j'aime pas
dans ce que ce qu'a fait michel cymes
c'est qu'il prend pas la mesure quand il
parle il n'a pas pris la mesure de la
maison j'ai comme tout le monde perse a
été préférée des français tout le monde
les coudes quand il a dit quelque chose
qu'il a dit que c'était pas grave ça se
trouve il ya des tas de gens qui ont
attrapé le coronavirus à cause de ce
qu'il a dit oui lieu de faire profil bas
on pense il ya plein de médecins congé
il n'a pas pris la mesure appelée ya
plein les doigts de mettre un cours dit
des bêtises
regardez jim et moi mais il sait qu'il a
dit des bêtises il l'a dit il a dit je
suppute est aussi j'ai pas qu'il est bon
mais il a été formidable
deux écoles deux écoles girouette
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait la déterminer la
télé j'allais à l'école je retourne dans
la médecine exactement profil bas je
vais au contact des gens ce qu il veut
attaquer les gens lui maintenant c'est
de notre faute si le virus
maintenant ça va être de notre faute
comme tu dis c'est propre passion et
elle a bien géré la crise en ce moment
il a lu et benjamin biolay d'arrêter
leurs six mois je déconne pas je parle
vraiment sarr et michel cymes jeudi
prend bien la mesure retourne un peu
l'hôpital voir ce qui se passe et après
on vient nous parler si tu veux